I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense the way that I would have said
it you know years ago was that the mind
can't tell the difference you know truth
or lie and that is essentially true the
difference between an actual event that
happened as a memory versus one that
you've created yeah through imagination
and dreaming and what did you call it in
the workshops your movie my movie yeah
mine movies yeah it's why is that oh
that's a good question well your brain
is a record of the past it's an artifact
of everything you learned an experience
to this moment it's a memory bank
of knowns that create your identity or
personality so then people most people
wake up in the morning the first thing
they do is start thinking about their
problems those are problems that are
literally itched in their brain with
certain people certain things certain
objects certain times and places the
moment they start remembering their past
or thinking in the past if you believe
that your thoughts have something to do
with your destiny right you're gonna
create more of your past in fact 90% of
the time but here's that here's the
important point when you're seeing that
image you're producing the same
chemistry in your brain and your body is
if the event was happening so thoughts
are the language of the brain but
feelings are the language of the body
the moment you start feeling unhappy now
your body's in the past and how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being so most people start
their entire day with their entire state
of being in the past now they're in
their familiar past that's the known
they will crave the predictable future
that's more of the known so they'll run
less effort just because they want to
predict the feeling of everything to
stay safe the unknown is a nun as scary
right so they run through a routine and
a habit on autopilot right so then if
you're not being defined by some vision
of the future you're left with the
memories of your past yes if you're not
in love with your future that means
you're more in love with your past and
you'll stop creating so when when a
person gets truly focused in athletes
and performers like you understand this
you spend a certain amount of time when
you close your eyes you start mental
rehearsing what you're doing yeah every
every move everything and when you're
truly present and truly focused your
brain does not know the difference
between the actual experience in your
life and and what you're imagining
inside of you is called mental rehearsal
an example they took a group of people
that never played the piano before they
divided it into two different categories
in one category they said we're going to
teach you one-handed scales and chords
you come for two hours a day you'll
practice for five days we'll scan your
brain at the beginning we'll scan your
brain at the end and we'll see if you're
making any changes in your brain so
these people show up they practice the
scales and chords for two hours at the
end of five days they have a whole new
set of circuits on the opposite side or
the brain nothing new there you learn
something new you make connections you
get some instruction get your body
involve the it your body involved you
you enrich the experiences in your brain
usually they play the guitar is a good
thing it's a great thing for your brain
you repeat it you pay attention new
circuits in your brain take another
group of people instead of them actually
physically playing the scales and chords
have them close their eyes and play the
scales and chords and mentally rehearse
them at the end of five days they had
the same amount of brain changes same
number of circuits in their brain as if
they were physically playing the
activity Wow
so another brain look like the
experience has already happened so
you're priming your brain from the past
it's no longer record of the past now
it's a map to the future and your body
will begin to instruct your mind take a
group of men have them close their eyes
and rehearsed doing bicep curls for an
hour on an hour day Cleveland Clinic an
hour a day for two weeks
stronger harder more intense at the end
of two weeks 13.5 percent increase in
muscle now never lifted a weight now the
body looks like it's been in the
experience now listen Oh see your
property and grow well they're stronger
okay stronger 13% stronger in two weeks
just by adding an emotional component
Wow so now the body doesn't know the
difference between the actual experience
and what the person's is image
now that's exactly how we begin to take
a person from one state of being to
another state of being in fact the more
you mentally rehearse the more you're
changing your brain into the future
your brain is remembering the future and
the stronger the emotion you feel when
you do it the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you pay attention
to what you're imaging and now you begin
to remember your future creating a
long-term memory just like when you have
a strong emotional event from your past
the stronger the emotion you feel the
more altered you feel inside of you the
more you narrow your focus on the cause
the brain takes a snapshot and that's
called the memory and people think
neurologically within the circuits of
that past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundary of their
emotions and now that's the state of
being so do the same thing now but
instead of having being an outer event
use your brain and use your body or use
your coherent heart coherent brain and
begin to combine a clear intention with
an elevated emotion and when you do that
properly the stronger the emotion you
feel the more you pay attention to the
pictures and now you're priming your
brain and body into a future you're
changing your state of being hmm and now
we keep doing that every day hmm you
down regulate genes for disease yeah
regulate genes for health the person
goes from being unhappy and patient
frustrated to being happy for no reason
at all
you